or looking for something me I've been
looking for my parents ever since
they've ditched me on a desert planet
then I found ancestry.com before I knew
it I had a new profile and was well on
my way to finding the true identity of
my parents when that first little leaf
appeared felt a force of excitement this
is a hunter we've been looking for I
learned that my mother's name was Mara
and she was this high-level government
assassin for an evil dictator she met my
father when she was sent on assignment
to kill him how romantic
and my father its Luke Skywalker I once
thought he was a myth but ancestry.com
was able to trace his records dating
back to the rebellion against the Empire
I don't know when I'm going to bring it
up to him though he hasn't said much
since I got here actually he hasn't said
one word to me in a year at least I knew
who my dad is
ancestry.com is amazing ancestry.com
we're theory becomes ganic start your
free trial today you were right Internet
so I wasn't sure if Luke Skywalker
really was my father seemed too easy so
I went back to ancestry.com and another
leaf led me to all these records so I
paid an extra six portions and found
traces of my history tied to Tatooine
and an old hermit by the name of Ben
Kenobi and if he's related to that
obi-wan Kenobi Luke mentioned I mean
there's no records of him off of
Tatooine other than he was last seen
leaving the system in a flying pile of
garbage and they both have the same
robes found another leaf yep my
grandfather is the jedi master named
obi-wan Kenobi I don't quite know how it
seems like a lot of dots to connect
and also said my grandmother was a
cartoon character whatever that is you
know not really sure what's going on but
yay ob1 right let's hope ancestry.com
got it right this time
ancestry.com we're theory becomes Canon
start your free trial today
you might be right Internet with
ancestry.com finding appearances not as
easy as it looks I paid in extra for
portions which is really going to suck
for me because I'm running out of water
and magic bread so when I logged in I
found another leaf so many leaves but
what I found was mind-blowing
it turns out my father was a smuggler
scoundrel nerf herder yeah han Solo who
I met right that doesn't seem right I
mean if he was my father I would have
wanted him to say something not just
stare at me like he felt guilty about
dropping me off here on jakku but that
might explain why that nice lady hugged
me at the end instead of Chewbacca also
I wish ancestry.com would have warned me
about my crazy brother who actually
murdered my father he can't be happy
with me because I nearly slashed his
face in half wouldn't stop whining oh my
face you wouldn't have done this to
Darth Vader Oh God
I'm gonna have to spend life day with
him so awkward ancestry.com
we're theory becomes canon start your
free trial today or don't because the
Internet can really mess with your head
I mean your site might be broken with
ancestry.com even the most idiotic
theory can find some sense of validity
apparently so
on solo isn't my father so confused and
everyone has an opinion yesterday some
weird white dude but the dirty beard
came up to me and started yelling that
my father was someone named Ezra Snoke
my friend Pablo got rid of him I just
want to know what my lineage is so I
went back to ancestry.com and now it
turns out there was this floating
severed hand in space and then that hand
made me so I guess I'm a clone I don't
understand anything anymore and I really
don't think anyone has any idea who I am
or where I come from ancestry.com
we're theory becomes canon start your
free trial today so no one has any idea
who my parents are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]